[Music]
later from a v2 rocket you've got the
most graphic actual pictures yet taken
by a camera showing how the earth looks
from a point 70 miles in space though no
man has yet been shot more than 15 miles
from his earth you now know how this
planet will look below you when you
finally venture beyond that height
in its gantry at cape canaveral florida
authorial rocket is ready to carry this
weather observation satellite on a new
space adventure and on command send
their scannings back to earth another
space triumph for the US which is
explained to Ike at the White House by
space agency head Glennon who produces a
picture sequence of the satellite
scanning
[Music]
success in space orbiter two heads for
the moon it inspires us to redouble our
efforts to bring peace and tranquility
to earth suddenly to see this delicate
colourful little planet of ours coming
up over the stark lunar horizon it was
the difference between the two that I
think impressed me in which I think
helped make her eyes picture iconic for
the environmentalists and others
[Music]
the Whole Earth Catalog the earth gauge
the various laws that float subsequent
to that picture
I wouldn't say picture was you know was
the only reason but it certainly was an
important reason motivating folks to
take better care of our planet
[Music]
it's got to be the most incredible earth
the Earth observing mission has both on
the quality of the data the global
survey aspects of the data and the
incredible longevity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]